ADVOCATES AND OTHERS.
NOW, BACK TO THE INGLE
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
♪ ♪
>> Laura: THE SANCTIONS ON
CHINA, THE TARIFFS, THE EXTRA
TARIFFS, IF THEY DON'T
FULFILL --
>> President Trump: I HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DO THAT BUT YOU HAVE TO
REALIZE, 25% TARIFFS ON CHINA ON
$250 BILLION WORTH OF GOODS.
I STILL HAVE THOSE.
BY THE WAY, REMEMBER, CHINA
DEVALUED THEIR CURRENCY AND PAID
FOR IT.
WE HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH CHINA RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK BADLY OF
ANYONE BUT THEY ARE HAVING THE
WORST YEAR THEY'VE HAD.
THE LAST YEAR WAS THE WORST YEAR
THEY'VE HAD IN 67, NOW IN 67
YEARS.
AND THEY WANTED TO MAKE A DEAL.
WE MADE A DEAL.
IT'S A GREAT DEAL.
NOW, IT WILL START AT SOME
POINT, BUT PHASE ONE WAS
IMPORTANT FOR BANKING.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DID, WE OPENED
IT UP FOR BANKING BUT FOR THE
FARMERS, MANUFACTURERS.
>> Laura: CHINA THOUGH --
>> President Trump: A LOT OF
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
KOREA, JAPAN.
>> Laura: UNDOCUMENTED, NO ONE
ELSE.
>> President Trump: REMEMBER
THIS, THEY ARE ALL KICKING IN
NOW WE DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING COME
A HORRIBLE DEAL NO DEAL.
WE ARE GETTING $40 BILLION.
WHAT THIS WILL DO FOR THE
ECONOMY IS GOING TO BE AMAZING.
AND JUST A MONTH AGO, IT IS JUST
NOW KICKING IN.
>> Laura: ON THE HUMAN RIGHTS
ISSUE IN CHINA, YOU DON'T TALK A
LOT ABOUT IT BUT THE STRONGEST
SUPPORTERS, EVANGELICAL
CHRISTIANS, CATHOLICS FROM OTHER
PEOPLE CONCERNED ABOUT HUMAN
RIGHTS.
A MILLION PEOPLE AND REEDUCATION
CAMPS, CATHOLICS GETTING
MISSILES AND THEY PEWS AT
CHRISTMAS HAD TRIBUTES TO SILENT
NIGHT.
RECONCILE THE POWER OF THE MORAL
ARGUMENT FOR FREEDOM AND MARRIED
IT TO THE ECONOMIC AND MILITARY
ARGUMENT FOR PEACE OR STRENGTH.
CAN YOU DO MORE ON THAT FRONT
WITHOUT DAMAGING YOUR ABILITY TO
MAKE FUTURE TRADE AGREEMENTS
MORE ON THE HUMAN RIGHTS FRONT?
>> President Trump: WE ARE
MAKING NOT GOOD TRADE DEALS BUT
GREAT TRADE DEALS.
>> Laura: HUMAN RIGHTS
ACCOUNT.
>> President Trump: THEY DO
COUNT.
WHEN YOU SAY REAGAN, LOOK AT MY
WAS A BIG FAN OF REAGAN BUT HE
WASN'T HEAVY INTO IT.
HE WANTED TO DO CERTAIN THINGS
AND WAS NOT HEAVY INTO IT.
BUT HE WASN'T MAKING TRADE
DEALS.
HE LET JAPAN COME IN AND TAKE
OUR AUTOMOBILE MARKET.
AS MUCH AS I LIKE RAG AND HE WAS
NOT GOOD ON TRADE.
>> Laura: HE DIDN'T TRADE WITH
THE SOVIET UNION AT ALL.
HE DIDN'T HAVE STUDENTS COMING
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
SPEED TWO BY THE WAY, GETTING
ALONG WITH RUSSIA, NOW THAT THE
WITCH HUNT HAS ENDED, NOW THAT
THEY SPEND $45 MILLION AND FOUND
NOTHING.
>> Laura: MR. PRESIDENT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE TRAJECTORY OF
YOUR PRESIDENCY, HUGE PROGRESS
ON TRADE AND HUGE PROGRESS ON
DEALING WITH POLITICAL FOES,
ISIS, INCREDIBLE DEREGULATION
JUDGES, YOU'VE DONE A LOT.
ON THE ECONOMY TODAY, WE FOUND
OUT THAT STILL 146,000 JOBS,
UNEMPLOYMENT HISTORICALLY THE
WET 3.5%.
BUT WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
STUMP ON WAGE GROWTH AND WE'VE
SEEN 2.9% LAST YEAR.
OVER THE LAST MONTH.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A TIGHT LABOR
MARKET AND IF WE DID COME A
INCREASES IN WAGES.
I HEAR THAT YOUR TEAM IS
PLANNING ON ADVOCATING MORE
FOREIGN WORK COMING IN FOR SOME
OF THESE HIGH-TECH COMPANIES.
ARE YOU VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT AS A LOT OF YOUR
SUPPORTERS?
>> President Trump: MARK LEVIN
A LITTLE BIT.
>> Laura: WE ARE CONCERNED.
>> President Trump: DOBBS IS
CONCERNED TOO.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM.
I AM DEMANDING THAT JAPAN ALL
THESE COUNTRIES THAT HAVE THESE
MASSIVE, DEFICITS LIKE NOBODY
HAS EVER SEEN BEFORE.
I SAID YOU TO OPEN UP AIKO
PRIME MINISTER, YOU HAVE TO OPEN
UP MORE PLANS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY TELL ME, WE WANT TO DO IT,
WE WANT TO DO IT.
THEY CAN'T GET LABOR.
WE NEED HELP, OTHERWISE, WE CAN
SAY DON'T OPEN.
>> Laura: IF THEY COULDN'T GET
LABOR, WAGES WOULD BE GOING UP
BUT WAGES ARE GOING UP YOU'RE
NOT IN THE HIGH-TECH INDUSTRY.
WE ARE TAKING A PLATEAU.
>> President Trump: IT WENT UP
2.9%.
THE LAST YEAR, THE WAGES HAVE
GONE UP MORE THAN THEY HAVE 25
YEARS.
>> Laura: BUT FOR GOOGLE, WHY
AWARD GOOGLE?
THEY ARE WORKING AGAINST YOU IN
THE CAMPAIGN.
>> President Trump: I'M NOT A
FAN.
I'M NOT A FAN OF GOOGLE.
>> Laura: YOU DID NOT BRING
FOREIGN WORKERS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> President Trump: WE HAVE TO
ALLOW SMART PEOPLE TO STAY IN
THE COUNTRY.
YOUR GRADUATE NUMBER ONE IN YOUR
CLASS AT HARVARD.
>> Laura: YOU RAN ON PEOPLE
TRAINING FOREIGN REPLACEMENTS.
YOU RAN AGAINST THAT.
THE AMERICANS HUMILIATING FOR AN
AMERICAN WORKER FOR 30 YEARS.
NOW, IT IS TOLD ME YOU HAVE TO
TRAIN FORMER REPLACEMENT, AND
YOU WILL PAY HIM 20%.
>> President Trump: I WOULD
NEVER DO THAT, BUT WE DO NEED
WORKERS AND THE COUNTRY.
AND I DO WANT IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
NOBODY'S BEEN BETTER ON
IMMIGRATION THEN MAY, BY THE WAY
WE WON THE FUNDING FOR THE WALL
AND THE WALL HAS BEEN BUILDING
BECAUSE TAKEN OUT OF THE
MILITARY AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
IT IS EASIER.
MANY PEOPLE COME I GOT FOX CON
TO GO INTO WISCONSIN.
THEY HAVE TO GET PEOPLE.
THEY SPENT A FORTUNE AND BUILT
THE MOST INCREDIBLE PLANT I'VE
EVER SEEN.
FOX CON.
>> Laura: AMERICAN GRADUATES
OF COLLEGES AND THE UNIVERSITIES
TAKING JOBS.
>> President Trump: WE DO BUT
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OF THEM.
WE HAVE TO BE COMPETITIVE WITH
THE REST OF THE WORLD TOO FOR
THE COMPANIES WANT TO HIRE THESE
PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY WANT TO HEAR PEOPLE
THEY CAN HIRE FOR THE CHEAPEST
AMOUNT.
>> President Trump: I'M
TALKING BRAINPOWER.
THEY WANT TO HIRE SMART PEOPLE.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE THROWN OUT OF
THE COUNTRY AND WE CAN'T DO
THAT.
>> Laura: YOUR BRAIN ON
AMERICA FIRST.
>> President Trump: THIS IS
>> Laura: I'M GOING TO KEEP
GOING.
>> President Trump: LET ME
FINISH.
IF WE TELL SMART PEOPLE TO GET
THE HILL OUT --
>> Laura: THAT'S NOT WHAT WE
ARE SAYING.
THERE IS A NEVER ENDING APPETITE
ON THE PART OF CORPORATE AMERICA
TO BRING IN AS MUCH CHEAP LABOR
AS POSSIBLE TO DRIVE DOWN WAGES.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> President Trump: SO MANY
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE COUNTRY,
YOU WON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
IT.
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE A SHORTAGE.
IF SOMEBODY IS IN THIS POSITION,
WE HAVE SO MANY COMPANIES COMING
IN FROM JAPAN.
JAPAN IS DOING MANY OF OUR
COMPANIES.
CHINA NOW IS GOING TO START
BUILDING A LOT OF THINGS.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN DOING IT TOO
MUCH.
WE HAVE SO MANY COMPANIES